so what is contact tracing and how does
it work well if a case of Kovac 19 is
confirmed individuals who have had close
contact with the person will be traced
and given advice on what to do if they
are on well or develop symptoms a new
NHS smartphone app is expected to play a
key role in identifying those who have
been exposed people with the app can
voluntarily opt in to record details of
their symptoms when they start to feel
unwell using short-range Bluetooth
signals the app will work out who that
person has been closed tube and will
anonymously there's other app users to
tell them and recommend they self
isolate or get tested if needed people
on the Isle of Wight will be the first
in the UK to trial the app next week I
look this this pilot scheme because it
protects the island better and it
protects my at-risk groups because the
tracked a senchan test scheme is going
to enable us to find where the virus is
on the island and by looking after those
people with it we can get to kill it
faster and the information that we're
going to give is going to provide a road
map to how the app functions in a 2-3
weeks time when it is rolled out
nationally the government says it needs
fifty to sixty percent of people to
download the contact tracing app for it
to be a success if all goes well the
technology will be rolled out nationwide
later this month